c'est en kyste ukrainien rentre du front
leur chat est un t64 l'un des fameux
modèles sans âges de l'époque soviétique
nous rejoignons l'unité de char qu'ils
viennent de remplacer
dire Darty en permanence dans cette
campagne du Dombas
nous sommes presque arrivé sur la
position de nos chars tirs
l'un des tanks est en lisière de forêt
caché sous les arbres
coup de canon vers les Russes juste en
face
la réponse de leurs ennemis ne tarde pas
ça tombe vers nous
c'était deux projectiles
avec un intervalle de 30 secondes
les tankistes à l'orée du bois n'ont pas
été touchées un équipage de trois
soldats les chars des occidentaux il les
attendent avec un patiente
les chariots
quand même
nous quittons cette forêt sur notre
route des chars Ukrainiens en panne
cachés sous les branchages pièces
manquent de pièces de rechange un
problème de matériel dont les soldats
parlent le temps permanence
nous suivons un entraînement de troupes
tout juste revenu du front de barmut
après quelques jours de repos seulement
ces soldats s'apprêtent à repartir au
combat
et on ne réussit pas toujours à
récupérer les corps des nôtres
on est rien
parfois vous vous dites c'est fini pour
moi
récemment j'ai été sous le feu d'un
lance-grenade ennemi un projectile est
arrivé tout prêt je me disais cette
fois-ci je ne vais pas m'en sortir
la plupart de ces combattants jeunes et
moins jeunes ont frôlé la mort ils ont
la fraternité pour tenir et repartir sur
le front